es ist der wirtschaftskrimi der
bundesrepublik deutschland die
spektakuläre pleite des
finanzdienstleisters wirecard aus bayern
weltweit beschäftigen die
staatsanwaltschaften geheimdienste und
auch finanz ermittler damit wo das geld
geblieben wissen wo die milliarden
veruntreut worden sind und einer der
chefs ist nach wie vor auf der flucht
abgetaucht wahrscheinlich mit
geheimdiensthilfe im bermuda dreieck
zwischen weißrussland und moskau
heute hat sich auch damit beschäftigt
der untersuchungsausschuss des deutschen
bundestages für den fall neuer card
erster zeuge gleich firmenchef markus
braun
der wurde um 12 uhr 25 angeliefert mit
einem grauen vw bus aus der
justizvollzugsanstalt augsburg
er hat die nacht verbracht in einer jva
hier in berlin brandenburg wurde dann
hierher gebracht eine stunde später kam
er dann vor den untersuchungsausschuss
verlas eine kurze erklärung und dann
folgte eine ziemliche frechheit er
berief sich selbst in persönlichen
angelegenheiten auf ein umfassendes
zeugnisverweigerungsrecht auf mehr als
100 fragen der abgeordneten antwortete
er nur in wechsel in wechselnden setzen
er werde sich bei seiner erklärung
hinaus nicht weiter antworten die
abgeordneten ließen nicht locker und
wollen jetzt sogar ein ordnungsgeld
gegen ihn verhängen und überlegen über
weitere rechtliche schritte
der fall ist damit noch lange nicht
abgeschlossen der deutsche bundestag hat
mit seinen ermittlungen begonnen und die
staatsanwaltschaft 1 in münchen hat ein
umfassendes ermittlungsverfahren gegen
zahlreiche beschuldigte eingeleitet
brown selbst das zumindest angekündigt
sich dort ein zu lassen hier heute hat
er nur eins gemacht er hat versucht die
deutsche politik und deutsche
aufsichtsbehörden pauschal
freizusprechen
ob man ihnen das glauben kann wohl kaum
der fall wird in die geschichtsbücher
der deutschen wirtschaftsgeschichte
eingehen
jetzt geht mir noch mal live zu peter
tiede er hat zum gespräch hans
michelbach er ist vize chef des wirecard
untersuchungsausschusses bei sich bitter
moritz danke aber zunächst noch eine
neue nachrichten ich habe ihn in der maz
kurz gesagt dass er angekündigt hat dass
brown angekündigt hat von der
staatsanwaltschaft ein zu münchen
aussagen zu wollen und
kooperationsbereit sei doch das war
seine erste aussage und seine erste
aussage war gleich eine lüge und zwar
eine wirklich freche lüge
wir haben nämlich nachgefragt weil der
staatsanwaltschaft münchen 1 und die
antwort ist er hat sich erst kürzlich
bei uns gemeldet und sei bereit aus sei
bereit sich vernehmen zu lassen das als
untersuchungshäftling muss er sich
natürlich wahrnehmen lassen aber von
kooperationsbereitschaft wisse man
nichts hätte man gewusst dass brown
tatsächlich kooperieren wollte hätte man
ihn längst vernommen also die antwort
war eine glatte lüge und dazu frage
jetzt hans michelbach vize-chef des
untersuchungsausschusses von der csu wie
glaubhaft war für sie herr braun heute
in seiner vernehmung herr braun hat sich
als dubiose personen dargestellt der
noch nicht begriffen hat dass er
rechenschaft ablegen muss
er hat keinerlei respekt vor der
öffentlichkeit kein respekt vor dem
deutschen bundestag kein respekt vor dem
recht stark gezeigt er hat gemeint er
ist noch der staat im staate wie er bei
wirecard auch sein unternehmen geführt
hat mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren